joe biden's press secretary jen sarkee
says that her boss intends to run for
re-election in 2024 prompting memes like
this in response
in joe's case even using the word run
feels optimistic this is a 79 year old
that struggles to walk sometimes
if biden were to run and that is a big
if and if he were to win an even bigger
hypothetical america's already oldest
president would surpass his own record
of being inaugurated at the age of 78 by
being inaugurated at the age of 82.
that's right and president biden is the
oldest sitting president in american
history his low-key media strategy means
that we don't get many press conferences
but we do get stories about his bodily
functions president biden farted while
speaking with britain's duchess camilla
parker-bowles he apparently passed wind
in front of her with a palace source
claiming his own emissions were long
and loud and impossible to ignore and
his health president joe biden is
undergoing a routine colonoscopy at
walter reed medical center today doctors
say he has some health issues like
throat clearing due to acid reflux and a
stiffened gait resulting from a recent
foot fracture and some spinal wear and
tear privately some democrats are
getting worried about the prospect of
biden's
2024 run this is from an ap article joe
biden's political standing is so weak
that he may not be able to win
re-election in 2024 if he were to run
again so even if he is somehow
miraculously fit enough to run he could
simply be too unpopular according to an
anonymous source speaking to the
washington post one democrat involved in
campaigns said they couldn't think of a
single person they'd spoken to in the
last month who considers the possibility
of biden running again to be a real one
if re-election isn't biden's real plan
he's effectively just freezing the field
for any alternative democratic
candidates but he doesn't have much of a
choice if biden announces now that he's
not going to run already then he will
officially make himself a lame duck
president he'll have no clout no power
on the international stage and all the
media attention will be focused on
figuring out who his successor might be